en una imagen de unidad y bipartidismo
que escasea desde hace tiempo en
washington el presidente joe biden firmó
una ley contra el racismo y los crímenes
de odio contra la comunidad asiática
americana apoyada ampliamente por
demócratas y republicanos
[Aplausos]
creo con cada fibra de mi ser que hay
simples valores y creencias
fundamentales que nos acercan y una de
ellas es luchar juntos contra el odio
contra el racismo
hate and cold day
estoy orgulloso de que demócratas y
republicanos se hayan alzado juntos por
algo
la ley fue aprobada con amplias mayorías
tanto en la cámara de representantes
como en el senado donde solo recibió un
voto negativo prevé mejorar la
prevención contra el racismo y reforzar
el sistema de registro de los crímenes
de odio
por acto de presentación se despide
pero después de que el presidente firme
esta ley hoy nuestro trabajo no habrá
terminado esta es la verdad el racismo
existe en américa work y el trabajo que
nos queda es hacer frente a la
injusticia donde sea que exista
las denuncias de racismo contra los
asiáticos en eeuu estallaron a raíz de
la pandemia muchos recuerdan como el ex
presidente de donald trump se refería al
nuevo coronavirus como el virus chino y
al kobe 19 como el kung fu
denuncian que sus palabras peyorativas
contribuyeron a crear un clima de odio
contra los asiáticos este llegó a su
máxima expresión en marzo de 2021 con un
tiroteo contra un salón de masajes en la
ciudad de atlanta que se cobró la vida
de 8 personas la mayoría mujeres jóvenes
de ascendencia asiática un tiroteo que
aceleró el avance de esta ley redactada
precisamente para evitar que crímenes
así vuelvan a suceder